I think they're gonna use like a New
York accent most southern some southern
classic California Valley gold maybe in
New York there last time I went out with
Brad you spill
Fago and better made chips all over me
he was trying to do Midwest but this
totally valid girl that's how people
talk to Michigan I'm gonna do a
Midwestern like you guys think mom dad
and pop we're going to the Tigers game I
mean a sword on you and all those people
up there Midwest good Iago yeah why are
the odds
Santiago things for Canadian and I'm not
okay with it where would they hear that
oh no Sarah Palin I'm from America and I
say words like alumina butts don't come
without the youth and they say America
isn't that a like a nonprofit
organization where it's like a little oh
yeah they say other minion I'm like a
Dunkin donut like Irish the sentences
they're using like they're all about
food but I've said that to my mom
multiple times if they're at my life you
know he looked at me and say you [ __ ]
your wife he's good he's pretty good you
can tell which TV shows get syndicated
abroad Godfather movies must come from
The Sopranos every mafia movie ever
I can't give you a good morning pizza go
next join Saint amant singing jump on
the horse cowboy and do it you'll be
that is like a New Orleans kind of
accident cowboy
jump on now your eyebrows are that calm
they get points in my book if they know
these fun words you always touch their
hair when they do California accent I
think that's part of being that oh my
god I didn't touch my hair a lot there
were small things in our lives that gave
us rolling like get us going
I love this like hey yeah Jackie you
should you should do going to voice
acting and that's a deep cut and that's
what we were looking for not repress
overall they see America a little bit
more accurately than I thought they're
hearing like Seinfeld and Friends it
just makes me happy to see what other
people think of us why can't we be like
hey ma'am I'd like to help you cross the
street I think that there are a hundred
percent better at doing American accents
when we are I think for an accent I'll
call my brother in faith hello you grew
up the year it's summertime in assisity
and where are these summer girls in two
outfits I'm a but some shrimp on the
barbie
porky bit me finger